um i almost think that that's why i'm so
successful out there
it's because i'm only inside and for me
there is no winning there is no smelling
roses one of the things i challenge
myself
is to get a little bit better at
smelling roses um
but i'm not even sure that's right
because i think the process is the rose
you know just playing is what i'm up to
i just want to play
[Applause]
you got your
i perspective want to be happy don't you
want to be happy
[Music]
can you tell us something really
down-to-earth about you well it's funny
even the nature of the question
makes me uncomfortable yeah so so the
meta
of the question is probably the most
down-to-earth thing about me meaning
i it's actually what i think a lot about
my favorite thing
is what people who actually have met me
say behind my back
yeah that that's the real answer i mean
the most down turn thing about me is
my parents and my circumstance created a
framework where
i'm unable to hear the cheering you know
and so i think one of the reasons i deal
well with
negative feedback is because of the way
i deal with positive feedback i think
the reason so many people struggle
with trolls or negative comments or
judgment is because they also
overvalue compliments yes so
i i for me i think it's that i have both
of my index fingers in my ears
what i mean by that is i just don't hear
either
and so for me humility is
the thing i'm most attracted to within
myself and in others
and so yeah just being uncomfortable
with the question i think is the most
downherd thing about me
yeah i love that so much i think in
every of
all the content i mean what i try to do
with each guest is research everything i
can about them
there is there's a lot of content on the
internet
but your humility and even calling you
know the latest wine company empathy
yes that alone is something that shines
through so strongly that you
have you know come from what you call
typical
immigrant upbringing and i i love that
it stuck with you the whole time
yeah me too me too i think one of the
things i most struggle with
you know i think fame and money and and
awareness
exposes people i don't think it really
changes people yeah
and um i think it really is sad to me to
watch
contemporaries or friends or
acquaintances when they do hit a little
bit
more awareness or more money that there
is an evolution in their personality
and i think that i don't think that's a
change i think that's who they actually
were the whole time
um so yeah i i i'm very grateful that i
don't have that dna trait that makes me
think i'm somebody
just because i may have some financial
or
large following success yeah well what
also is in your dna is this
entrepreneurial trait and this
incredible ability to be
ahead of the curve and to see i have
this intuition that lets you see
what other people don't is that what the
next five ten years are going to look
like yes
so in terms of your weight ea that's
pretty much the story of how you got to
a life that makes you yay
take us back to the very beginning
because i think anyone who's looking to
you for guidance of how to find what
lights you up and and our lives we're
expected to have so many different
careers in our lifetime now it's so
overwhelming
take us back to young gary like born in
the soviet union
was born in the soviet union moved to
queens for a couple years then moved to
new jersey
um very close to his mom dad's working
every minute doesn't really have him in
his life the first 15 years because he
just worked so hard
um 14 years and then i started working
in my dad's liquor store so i got to
really know him but
but just quickly gravitated towards
business
you know six seven eight years old
lemonade stands shoveling snow
washing people's cars baseball cards you
know
all those things and so much like
somebody is a
natural athlete or a natural singer
songwriter you know every time i watch
videos of young lebron or young beyonce
i always think man i wish my mom i wish
there was recordings of me at baseball
card shows or behind a lemonade stand at
eight years old there was a natural
talent that i had in selling
and so yes i you know it's so
interesting to be in the prime of my
life
during the rise of entrepreneurship you
know it's on a pedestal it's cool now
you know it's crazy for me because when
i was selling stuff in high school
it was dorky it was nerdy it was like
you know making money was
not cool it was it was being good at
school or being good at sports so
it's very weird it's very weird for me
to have
admiration or recognize that rappers and
athletes and actors and actresses all
want to be entrepreneurs now and so it's
it's very cool in a lot of ways but i
also have
concerns about people forcing themselves
into entrepreneurship
when i know that it's really lonely it's
really difficult
um and it's just not for everybody yeah
well i loved you know i was listening to
her
i think it was two years ago you were on
joe rogan and one of the things you
pinpointed about yourself that makes you
dna you know entrepreneurial to your dna
not just in aspiration
is that a six-year-old gary had you know
gary's lemonade stand had
multiple venues and you weren't just the
kid that wanted to sell stuff
you were looking more at where you would
put the sign
to get the most sales funnel towards the
lemonade stand like i don't even know
how a six-year-old
could conceive of those it took me 30
years to even know that i was giving a
speech
and i just kind of was giving my same
standard first five minutes of my speech
and i just remember it very clear i just
stopped i'm like wait a minute
i used to sit i mean how i mean this is
just like weird
i used to sit and watch these cars drive
by
and be and literally take my sign and
move it you know drock's in the
background right now filming
uh some stuff and he got to see me in
action this last week
in chicago at a baseball card show it's
the first time i was a dealer in 25
years
and i mean the way i was moving around
the tables and changing stuff and
changing prices and signs and angles
you know that's what i did and that's
what i do in content and on these
platforms the way i think about linkedin
and facebook and twitter and youtube and
my podcast and email service and
text messaging platform it's a lot of
the same thing it's attention
hacking it's attention arbitrage and
it's not only attention
hey here's the best part of my table or
hey here's instagram
it's also what am i gonna say yeah
what's the you know what's the
language and the sign what's the copy
i'm gonna put what's the title of the
meme
um it is something i've always done yeah
it's
so cool watching your story how it
literally just from strength to strength
evolved through from sex from your first
business at six to everything that
you've since
touched so you moved into the family
business yes 14 sure
discount liquors yes did a little
rebrand yes
and it became the wine library yes so a
deep love for
wine and sales and
very big theme of my life collecting
wine was a huge reason
i fell in love with it because i was
transitioning off
collecting cards it was a big big big
theme of my life
and i mean you turned that business into
e-commerce before e-commerce was like a
word
how did you do that i mean how do you
firstly up-skill without
i mean you you went to college you went
you know you went through school but how
do you upskill to knowing before
before there's a garyvee i mean who was
your garyvee firstly
at your age was there was there a you
who was significant content and
no democratizing let me rephrase i'm
sure
i mean you know actually actually
somebody who i'm very fond of
historically is barbara walters
i thought barbara walters was an
incredible journalist and
and incredibly smart about culture and
people
but i didn't look up to business people
uh
leveling up did not happen in school
yeah it came
in the trenches in the dirt and
the internet you know i had probably
been on a computer
on a computer for less than two hours in
my life
when i decided to launch winelibrary.com
oh my god i mean
like four months no youtube didn't come
out for 10 years after that oh my gosh
wine library tv oh yeah yeah was four
months after youtube this is 1996
10 years before youtube came out nine
and a half um
i just inherently understand people yeah
like deeply same reason i knew that vr
wasn't going to be big in a year or two
two years ago when everybody was going
on that bandwagon
i would look i look i watch i'm watching
what your fiance's wearing like that i
literally like that's what i do
you look great you know like like you
know i look at the haircut he's wearing
i look at like
everything i watch i watch i'm an
anthropologist
you know i think if my dna was slightly
to the left or right
i'd be one of those people that goes
into the amazon and
for 29 years of their career follows
red-headed ants
in the amazon i'm that curious by
behavior
luckily for me well not luckily for me
the way that's manifested
is in people and then trends and
behaviors
around business but that maps to how we
look at social issues
politics you know which diseases or
issues like why are we passionate right
now about
plastic straws to paper straws i'm
fascinated by why that's the issue we
decide
while textiles you know continue to do
enormous damage to earth and we've got
people who are
yelling about the environment wearing
gucci belts
yeah i'm fascinated by that what do you
choose to do
what do you choose not to do you know
why coffee
over tea you know in our culture today
like just those kind
i'm always thinking but most of all
and this is where humility comes in and
i'm gonna round this up
i never think i get to pick
i never get to impose i don't think i
get to say what it should be and i think
a lot of people think that way
i watch and just react to what people
are doing
yeah i love that you just ask the
questions that kind of give us the
answers rather than like
just hammering answers down our throat
you invite conversation and you use your
platforms to really get us to think
about i'm an anthropology nerd as well
like i did
law arts but i did all my thesis on like
studying what people do and why they do
it it's why i find like war history in
the ussr like
this stuff is so interesting it's huge
to me right like i leave a place of
of communism i go to a place of
capitalism you know
i i'm also driven by gratitude i
genuinely think if me and my
grandfathers
both of them for that matter switch
spots i'm the one who spends 10 years in
a communist jail
they're the ones who get accolades in
the current world so
you know i'm driven by gratitude like
just completely and utterly driven by
gratitude yeah
i was um adopted from an orphanage in
south korea same thing
came here i was like it could have been
so different which is so different
every second is like make the most of
every opportunity that there is out
there
100 percent to use platforms adversity
at a young age is an
incredible foundation of success yeah
absolutely you know you and i
had to live our whole lives once it
started becoming aware to us what our
circumstance was
understanding like thank god yeah no
matter what was hard no matter if it was
hard being
for me in a family that was trying to
make its way and
and it was a struggle early on or for
you having to think about like
the dynamics of being adopted or no
matter how hard it was
there was still a part of your brain
mind that understood there was
an incredible luck and great gift that
was given
which creates and really interesting
framework of just
ambition you know gratitude
just a good mix of things that tend to
work out yeah
so things have worked out so incredibly
well for you with that drive
and like intuition from building the
family business i think it was 3 million
to 60 million
through just taking it over then
vaynermedia in 2011 founding it with
your brother
you've got askgaryvee you've got the
dailyvee you're like literally the most
prolific content creator in the world
which is absolutely incredible because
you use it
to inspire you know future generations
to think about what they're doing and
not just be on this conveyor belt of
achievement which is what cj's all about
instead of seeking the day all the time
you've got to find your joy and do what
matters to you
i'm on an incredible mission an
incredible mission
to redefine the north star from
financial success
to a happiness conversation i really
believe
it can be achieved i'm flabbergasted
by what has transpired over the last
three years in watching a lot of young
alpha males
convert in front of my eyes from guys
that would do cliche dumb [ __ ] in their
20s with girls and money
to ones who talk about empathy and
kindness and gratitude
and it is not lost on me that i am
taking the gifts that my mom and dad
gave me
and i'm giving them to the world and my
happiness framework
and the way i treat people is for some
reason becoming cool
and if and i'm just gonna squeeze the
[ __ ] out of that because
it's leading to good yeah so how do you
like in that whole anthropological
discussion of redefining success from a
financial metric
and an external validation that's right
to an international
yes fulfillment metric when did you
click over
to i'm successful or what does that feel
like for you
and you know imparting to you you've got
two beautiful children and there i'm
sure have had their own lemonade stands
what is the metric of success or feeling
or definition that you want to impart to
them
well a it's for them not to feel like
they have to eliminate stance so like
she has no interest in
i'm always like let's sell slime or
listen that she's like no i'm like great
awesome you do you
showing a little bit of an ability to
flip cards so that's exciting for me as
you can imagine but
i want them to love their game as much
as i love mine and whether that
is being a professor in a college which
would be really ironic and funny
or um you know a sculptor in egypt
like i i or or a stay-at-home dad you
know
for me as long as they're on fire the
way i
am then i've achieved my goal
for them and to be honest i don't even
even that sentence was funny to me i i
don't even want to impose a single thing
other than you know making sure they're
good human beings
um that matters to me and make sure
they're not entitled i have to be very
careful of that given
the financial circumstances they're
growing up in um
that's really it that's it as far as
like when it clicked for me
it clicked in a couple different ways i
remember the first day
literally i kind of getting really
interesting goosebumps like different
kinds like inside that outside
i haven't talked about this thing i got
a little emotional just now the first
day of my career
that first day that first day that i was
like i'm done with college
i will never have to go to [ __ ]
school again and i
will never forget that monday morning in
the liquor store
it was the great it might still be my
favorite day of my life
it was just like i knew i was on the
beginning of
the thing that i was meant to do which
is
you know be a professional businessman
and so
that was amazing literally that day i
felt successful and then
and then you know
honestly all the accolades like building
up the business making the smart
investments in facebook twitter all that
stuff tumblr
vayner becoming garyvee quote unquote
writing those
books and speeches and the millions of
followers
there's i'm i'm i don't
i don't see things like
in that way i i'm aware like when i did
planted the apps with gwyneth paltrow
william and jessica alba i was aware on
apple's
platform i was aware like oh this is
cool like uh this is another level up
for me and positioning to them but
you said something so incredibly
profound i am so
inside i'm so inside you know i'm
only in internal validation i'm not an
external validation which looks like a
contradiction to the way i roll
because i'm so out there um i almost
think that that's why i'm so successful
out there
it's because i'm only inside and for me
there is no winning there is no smelling
roses one of the things i challenge
myself
is to get a little bit better at
smelling roses um
but i'm not even sure that's right
because i think the process is the rose
you know just playing is what i'm up to
i just want to play
so much so that i even like when i lose
that's the best sound bite i've ever had
because there's a whole segment called
play tier which is forcing
every guest to stop and pull their
identity away from their output
because we're human beings we're not
human doings and not be achieving not be
successful and what is the activity that
you do and some people are like damn i
have nothing i don't play
i don't play for joy i literally just go
after goals
and that's there's no row smelly like
what is it all about if you want
so for me it cut that gets synthesized a
little bit differently to me
all of it's playing yeah and
all of it's smelling roses which is what
i love about you because i think
people do sometimes try and get this
fitting in the boxes it's a very
artificial
distinction between work and play if you
are on fire for what you do it's all
work and it's all play
literally my favorite things to do are
going garage sailing buying stuff and
flipping it on
like i get this and i've said this often
and it is absolutely true
and it just is i
i get a much bigger high of buying
something for eight dollars at a garage
sale
and selling it for 26 bucks on ebay than
i do in landing a five million dollar
client it's not even close
arbitrage i mean arbitrage it's just
buying and selling
yeah gives me a high that you know
nothing else does
and so you've also said something really
interesting recently with which kind of
landed really strongly for me was that
it's so important to
always have a goal that's not i mean
followers financial
if you're always going after that you
can hit the top but for you like with
the new york jets your goal
is to own that football team that's
right but you were like if i did it
what would i have to aim for anymore
like it's scary to achieve the goal so
you have to
tie it to something that will always be
to aspire to otherwise if you hit it too
easily like what's left and i think
and i think that for me that's a good
point and i think another thing that's
interesting to me
is i think you need to have a selfish
and a selfless goal and i think they
need to be as big as possible so i think
one of the things that makes me happy is
my goal professionally to buy the new
york jets and then to win super bowls
should keep me busy for 30 40 50 years
which is nice long time
my goal to be the most giving
entrepreneur of all time
is something that will take me my whole
life yeah you know
and it's extremely selfless like i
am extremely proud and quite conscious
not just subconscious now at this point
that i
am going to impact a lot of people and
it feels really good
admiration is a lot more exciting
than a couple extra zeros in your bank
account
and so yeah and that's why i love this
platform so much because when you can
show the human side of people everyone
is just a person
that you being just a person but using
the incredible impact you have
for the positive benefit of people out
there in society it's so
exciting like you have made me so
excited for humanity
i agree i think i think a lot of people
are confused right now and they see the
negatives
in social and digital and they're seeing
people scale hate
what they don't understand is it scales
everything
yeah and it's on us if you're so happy
then start putting happy into the
universe
yeah you know right now the people that
are most unhappy
are the ones who are loudest in their
content on social
nobody tweets great job qantas on the
flight we just took
a machine just went in the air landed
safely
i had a nice coffee i had wi-fi i bought
some sports cards
i don't land and tweet qantas great job
on my flight today
but if it was a three-hour delay and
they were out of coffee the amount of
people that tweet
you know [ __ ] you qantas you know people
are unbelievably interesting to me
we stay very the 98 that are happy
are staying quiet and the two percent
that are miserable are loud
and it confuses the other 98 and uh
i don't want to do that right i think
you can use it i'm a complainer on
twitter
but i also made sure recently when we
open the restaurant
everyone wants to complain especially so
now we're really conscious of
always do the good news and that's the
thing i tell a lot of my friends i'm
like don't wait for europe
for you to be on the other side of it
like recognize what we're doing and so
for me
i'm putting it you know when i i mean i
think this morning on the way to shower
i
tweeted a blue heart that was it and
like
and that's just nice i mean i don't know
if they went wild but i think one human
seeing that maybe just thought that's
nice like like
to me we need to start doing that we
need to make like maybe this is the
podcast this is the moment like
let's make a call to arms like if you're
in a good mood [ __ ]
share it like because because this tiny
percentage and i mean
guys the reason we are still here all
these years later
is human beings are remarkably good to
remind everybody
we have had atomic bombs that can wipe
us off the face of the earth now
for 70 years we're here we we've had
genocides holocausts we've had the black
plague
we've had world wars we're here and
everybody spirit
is unstoppable and everybody's dwelling
right now
on a rise of nationalism and hate which
is terrible
however let's contextualize it and
instead of judging people and calling
them racists
or bad people why don't you go loud
about good
instead of getting sucked in to being
doing more hate around people who hate
why don't you actually combat it why
don't we learn from
martin luther king and from gandhi and
from other people in the past
which is you do not defeat hate with
hate on hate
you defeat hate with love at scale and
we all have
our 14 followers our 1000 followers our
eight followers
and instead of flexing about your new
handbag
or your hot new sneakers or the hike you
took
or the remarkable meal you're having
what about putting out good what about
co-signing somebody that did something
nice
what about watching somebody open the
door for an old lady and roll up on them
and make a video
and tell them about this nice kid we
need to get
louder about happiness uh if we all
collectively do that
i have a funny feeling the internet will
feel a lot more happy yeah i mean that's
what this is there's a little quote book
it's called cca it's like the podcast
it's a happy quote for every day
i love that and people like everywhere
just i'm like life is pretty awesome i
mean we're
in a really exciting time it's a great
time to be alive be excited
about it 400 trillion to one yeah
400 trillion to one that is the current
scientific odds around being a human
being
and that's something that uh did you
know that 400 trillion to one you are
more likely to get struck by lightning
10 times in your life than have one
it is the great miracle like that whole
miracle concept like you're the baby's a
miracle it's actually true
it's actually true and so people are
walking around moping about
their mom being a jerk or their or their
brother
stealing their money or somebody
or their pimple on their face or they
can't get a new
supreme or i mean just or that somebody
snake is sold out so [ __ ] up
or like stuff that i don't know why this
specific thing drives me crazy people
yelling at baristas for using the wrong
milk i mean that to me
i don't know what it is about that one
you know people literally yelling at
somebody no almond
milk you [ __ ] they just bought a six
dollar coffee like do you know how
blessed you are
like i mean i mean a nine dollar coffee
gary come on
respect so just to wrap up quickly i
want to
give a little shout out to one of our
dear mutual friends justin dry and the
incredible work that he's doing with
vino yes
yes you are here to launch empathy wines
in australia yes which is so
so exciting so just quickly give a
rundown on that so i started a winery
almost a year ago called empathy wines
the ambition is to produce
an incredible wine in the in us dollars
a 40
wine for 20 bucks obviously there's some
price variations here in australia
just and i have been friendly for a long
time we only wanted to sell direct to
consumer from winery to
people in america he reached out we got
into a conversation there's such warm
feelings there in admiration
we got into a combo and binomofo is the
exclusive partner
of being able to sell the wine outside
the u.s in the australian new zealand
and
singapore market uh and uh the response
has been remarkable
in this marketplace and it's a beautiful
rose thank you californian gray and the
white just came out
and the red and the red will be coming
out in the fall and so
it's um it's been an incredible project
and
it's really you know it's funny when i
was making the rose
i was thinking about an australian rose
there's an australian rose that i'm very
fond of called turkey flat
uh and i remember as i was blending it
the whole time i'm like i'm going to
make a better rose than turkey flower
i'm going to make a better rose
and with spring angel those were the two
things i was thinking about and so um
it's been a lot of fun and and the
partnership with mino mofo has been
extremely seamless and completely built
built on kindness and friendship and
empathy
um and uh and i'm enjoying it so
exciting to see it go live tonight thank
you
we'll be playing two last questions yes
what are the three most interesting
things about you that don't normally
come up in conversation
and you're probably the hardest guest to
come up with anything that hasn't been
on a podcast before
i'm remarkably non-confrontational in
real life even though i'm a tough guy on
video and stage
nice uh i sleep seven to eight hours a
day
no yep amazing i mean six one
and five when i travel and
i really don't i genuinely don't care if
i'm financially successful
like like deeply like almost to the
point where
i have to be careful because i almost
can feel as i'm evolving
the want to sabotage myself
i'm not kidding i like really have to be
thoughtful like i'm really
having a very interesting time with
myself where i'm like man i really
like almost like like almost and i've
said it a lot which means it's like like
i get into this weird like am i gonna
become like a weird monk and just
disappear like
i'm am i going to i'm just all about
happiness
like and and maybe my version of a weird
monk is
actually to just become a junk and and
baseball card dealer right like just
really go there but i can feel it in me
you're gonna marry condo yourself
this is what's next maybe i'm just a
very i'm a just a
i'm things are very clear to me i like
that and they have nothing to do with
the modern
version of success this is not about
stuff
uh this is about waking up and not
having anxiety
i love that and final question for
yourself what's your favorite
motivational quote
i don't know it can be a garyvee code
that's also fine you can make it up
i will and i can tell you like what i
think about which is
kindness is karma right give more than
you take
and probably wrapping it up like
probably my favorite thing to say
because it hits people once in a blue
moon doing the right thing is always
the right thing